let's try this I might go into the Alpen
c-45 No okay well what are some things
you think about when you see this III
move do you view it as just the light
square bishop would come out what more
do you think to yourself when you see
III because I'm thinking something more
than just this bishop coming out all
right let's get night here any thoughts
on what else I might be thinking beyond
just this bishop being able to come out
anybody know in the twitch I'll try to
take a peek at certain things that come
into the chat I think it's a good idea
to be subjecting your own thoughts to
these positions if you're really trying
to use this as some sort of the way to
improve your own game before I maybe
even share my own thoughts on why you
know why this what's going on exactly
anyhow I'm liking c5 in the knight c6
okay I'm not sure exactly what's coming
and I really do want to focus on the
game but it could be good just for the
chat to be interacting with one another
on things but I see it as okay of light
square Bishop is coming out the D for
squares reinforce so I'm anticipating
not only an eventual c4 move but I'm
pretty much assured that this Bishop is
gonna have to be fee and ketab and a lot
of attention might be given to the e5
square or maybe should be given
attention by me because this night could
be playing here at any moment and I
already has enough support now that the
bishop is on b2 rook c8 Bishop d6 pawn
takes you might want to consider just
pawn takes right now yeah I want to I
want to be assured of some things I want
I want to see what how what type of
recapture will be a pond will be a
knight
tonight so I'm not gonna really have to
worry about the e5 square anymore since
there isn't a pawn on d4 not gonna have
to worry about a knight in my territory
on my floor ranks to the board
there is tension between these bishops
let's get rid of the tension and now
it's either rook c8 Bishop e7 Bishop d6
well Bishop d6 is the more aggressive
but I don't maybe maybe I don't want to
be tethered to the defense of my knight
in case there's a knight takes maybe I
want to have my bishop here to watch
over my knight my queen could go out and
do other things so I'm gonna make a more
passive looking move but that's in order
to allow for my queen to do more stuff
so I'm not sure if there was a
significant difference between rooks EI
and castles there I'm gonna play this
right now and I'm threatening with this
last move Knight takes filed by rook
takes on C which is met nicely
interesting okay now maybe regretting
not playing my Bishop to d6 because I
guess maybe coming back to be 8 and then
Queen d6 stuff at least forcing a knight
to maybe play to f3 to defensive to
defend against the mate my opponent is
um is really flying here I'm shooting up
a lot of time Queen d5 eventually I just
want to go there and yeah let's try this
clean here yeah just see I'm talking
about Bishop d6 back up and then try and
get some battery here force one of these
nights into a defensive I think g3 would
be too weakening somehow and I think I
could capture like this and then just be
prepared to run somewhere cozy is this a
cozy square hopefully it is light square
by
those are the ones that I'm looking into
the most well yeah I mean if I have a
choice I'd really like to keep it on
light square so this guy isn't gonna be
a problem
there's 95
well if 95 I'm also eyeing see too
that's another thing that I could be
saying to myself I didn't see that
initially I'm just seeing it right now I
want to get out of get out of danger
right away
okay let's double up that can't be bad
can it I need a flight square I'm still
in need of a flight square here my
opponent has all their pieces out and
working this is a good setup for white
here maybe something like Queen b5 might
have been better just putting pressure
on this pond why didn't I consider Queen
B 5 yeah I mean I could still go in this
direction pressure on this point but you
know maybe I want to throw in B 5 and
that's something that could be
threatening right now so we'll see if
I'm intimate if I'm to make a flight
square where do you think I would go
which pond should I move okay well I'm
gonna go two squares with this just
light square for a flight square also
secures my queen position a little bit
more just so there's not any out you
know some some crazy timely g4 stuff so
is a force sniffing out this idea of B 5
or Queen a 5 now we have a Queen trade
okay well I think I'm okay with going
for the Queen trade and I think I want
to baby step
some stuff here what I mean by that baby
step it if I played a six trying to get
him B five blacks that white says no a
five stops me cold all righty
I am feeling the pain here I feeling the
pressure this night in order for me to
make progress I really do feel like this
night needs to go somewhere else less
than 50 battling back timewise this is a
really tight game really really tight if
the knight moves I'll probably throw the
rook immediately here let's do it
it's a drawback with that there is no
rook I got a pig on the second I have to
watch out for this square if I'm in
check and I go here I'm dropping f7 that
might happen might okay I really don't
want to assign a babysitter to that beep
on so let's just move them no
babysitters okay
remove that 40-minute down 94 let's go
night I'm on f2 are they gonna go
defensive I could take this pawn but
there would have been rook here now I
can maybe do f6 at some point although
not here's available it's gonna get
tricky tricky nest trickiness Knights
tricky Knights 92 check a ruski grab a
bishop kill a king right here okay let's
get this night out of here first
not sure why check watch out King could
be very scary bishop check here
running scared back rank issues okay now
this is need any gap on and if I'm not
mistaken I just pushed this guy to
victory lane
looking for Victory Lane and my opponent
is being passed they're saying no you
will not play e4 so easily I understand
that I understand that let's back up now
that Knight is gonna get he's uh doesn't
have a home just yet so I can't go too
far so push push move the rook away push
push
it's the plan less than 20 about 30 for
white let's go let's go keep going
rook here I think no let's do this just
so this pawn is watching out for flight
squares
maybe Bishop here was somehow better
just gonna the king is in a giant knot
I'm gonna play here so there's no rook
getting behind that pawn okay it ah I
should I just give a maid
okay well it's unavoidable still but I
should have just went here immediately
this is back rank problems so there's
still no defense to it but down to the
wire without it down very good game Mr D
wins let me hit go back and flip this
what is the scoop with this game let's
see
very nice again III could already be
saying yourself that dark seer bishops
most likely gonna be fee and keto this
is a solid set up for like Age 3 allows
for a late game and endgame well it's an
asset for the end game having a flight
Square already available and these moves
are watching out for maybe Knight or
Bishop check part not Knight and Bishop
checks but either the knight or Bishop
to making use of that Square and look
what could I have been doing better
again I don't know I mean my opponent
played a good game they played logical
moves and they were good moves
like right here I would be really
curious to know what a computer is
saying right here and I think it is
really close to just equal I don't know
maybe even bet White's better I don't
know okay I have the double some
pressure on the C file but this bishop
is better placed than my bishop so right
now what I'm doing is a piece comparison
who stands better if I'm just walking
along a table of chess boards which is
something I like to do when I'm at
tournaments I'm just like trying to do
quick I just tend to do quick
assessments like okay who stands better
and why whose pieces and this okay well
a quick thing I would do is just like
all right who has is the material
balance that's what I'm trying to get
Isaac is it balanced and if it is okay
who stands better positionally well I'd
have you seen this bishop better place
than this guy these two rooks may be
standing better than these two maybe the
black queen is a little bit better than
the white queen so and maybe the Knights
are kind of offsetting each other or
something but I don't know it seems
roughly equal right here as best I could
guess I could say right here so where
did um where did white maybe go wrong
how about how about just keeping this
tension and working on getting your King
a little bit more involved although I
guess I do have a follow-up of Knight
here which is a bit annoying forcing you
to make a decision so yeah okay this
this right here there there has to be
something here maybe maybe this is a
step in the wrong direction somehow with
the Queen coming over hmm
I mean there could always be maybe
Knight here somehow Knight here know
that no no scratch that that's dropping
a piece Knight here a bunch of trades on
this square then Queen takes Knight so
how about well it's still around with
Queen c2 I don't know what's the
improvement here hmm
what is this scoop I'm struggling here
to find something and I don't know okay
the the bishop comes up that seems like
it's okay and maybe here maybe maybe
it's not a good idea to bring my other
rook that really isn't doing anything
other than watching over this maybe it's
not a good idea to bring that to life so
I like that I think I like the bishop
move but right here maybe that's an
improvement how about something like F 3
and E 4 hmm F 3 and E 4 just to knock
this night out restrain it I'm not sure
you could probably hear it in my voice
and how I'm fumbling over my words here
to come up with something it was just a
really tight game so I don't know very
good
we were both in we didn't have so much
time right here towards the end so it's
hard to come up with some accurate stuff
I do want to touch on something else
that I'm learning right here this H 5
move is I think I referenced it doing a
couple things but seeing how this game
played out you know there's what I would
consider an additional reason for
wanting to go 2 steps with this pun it's
ok first and foremost flight square for
the King secondly it's to preserve this
Queens position in case there's a g4
those were the two I referenced during
the game but an additional one is you
know if you know I could always maybe
lock down on h4 and it becomes a bit
awkward you know I could be gaining some
space
and clamping down on g3 I really
couldn't anticipated that it would work
out like that but I don't see it as a
liability being on h5 opposed to h6 I
see it as doing many many good things
you could kind of look into that
especially as the position becomes a bit
more simplified in a chess game right
here in this middle game pretty much
endgame ish type of position you could
be looking to get more out of your pawn
moves not just flight Square but
watching out for the Queen's position
and also maybe even some attack or
something to do with that control of the
g3 square